What if we wee painting all of the spaces in a checkerboard, and we were
painting them blue and red? When we're drawing this rectangle we need to figure
out whether it's going to blue or red based on the number of its indexes. We
want to write a method that takes the row and the column of a space, and then
gives us a one. If the space should be red and a zero if the space should be
blue. The public interface of this method might look like this. So, we need
some mathematical expression which takes a row and a column and gives back a
one or a zero. If the row and the column are both even or both odd, you should
get back a zero. If the row is odd but the column is even, then you should get
back a one for red. And if the row is even but the column is odd, you should
also give back a one. In the checkerboard project that we provided for you in
blue jay, you'll want to implement checkerboard painter, and write a test
method in checkerboard painter tester. Try running the main method of painted
checkerboard. Once you've finished, if you need a hint, think about what
happens if you add an even number to an odd number. Do you get an even number
or an odd number?